I'm going to bring you some breaking
news on Tokyo's elections the leader of
the Homeland party is pulled out of the
race and Let's cross straight away to
maharabara who joins us live from Ankara
Hashem tell us what more you know at
this point
next so it was a decision by the leader
of the Homeland party Muharram ancha to
pull out of this race saying that he has
been accused over the last few days by
different parties which he said they are
affiliated with the other rival
political parties what he described as a
character assassination and then he is
saying that he's withdrawing from this
re from this race for the sake of
democracy and this is quite a
significant step now in this election
for the simple reason is that because
this is widely seen as a very tight race
was likely projected to come third in
this election either after
um president
of the arc party or kamales of the CHP
party Muhammad was the former member of
the CHP have run in the 2017.
18 elections against
30 percent of the uh votes and then when
he lost in 2018 a leadership race of the
CSP party he stepped out and he formed
his own political party until yesterday
the opposition was concerned that
Muharram ansha was going to bite into
its own support base and because Nick
this is going to be perhaps the toughest
race in the modern history of Turkey
was pretty much concerned that
insha could be the one who's going to
deny him from any chance to win this
election now we have to wait and see
what happens to the supporters of bahram
and they're going to give their voices
to the opposition or are they going to
migrate to someone like sinan we have to
wait and see but this is something that
is definitely going to change the
Dynamics of this election is it going to
be
first the round we'll have to wait and
see whether it's going to pave the way
for a second run the opposition mainly
is in favor of a scenario where it goes
to the second round but is more support
to win the election
so interpulling out could have major
implications on the outcome of these
elections just tell us just how close is
it
that it's so close to the point that
people now are talking about the new
voters about five million new voters in
this elections could have a a say and
these are young New Generation voters
who are likely seen to be giving their
voices to younger candidates
is 59 years old is 56 years old and
because this is going to be a tight race
we're up to this point no one can come
out and say he's confident he's going to
win the vote and over the next coming
days is going to be boiling down to who
is going to build Bridges with the swing
voters the opposition particularly
who wants to win the presidency and who
wants his party to win the present
parliamentary election the major
obstacle he faces is
winning more votes now with muharam
instead putting out his company evident
what he's going to do next he will try
to ask Muharram and his people to vote
for him for this election he knows that
those votes could definitely determine
what happens particularly during the
first round of this election Hashem
thanks very much indeed that's the
latest news from Turkey and that's it
from me Nick Clark more on our website
Al jazeera.com bye for now